for TV and movie fans alike there's
nothing quite like finding a real hidden
gem
luckily Netflix is full of them from the
sublime to the terrifying to the
outright ridiculous here are some of the
most underrated titles on Netflix today
dolomite is my name may have been a huge
critical success when it was released in
2019 but the movies snubbing by the
academy at that year's Oscars was
nothing less than scandalous so what's
all the fuss about though a might is my
name tells the true story of Rudy ray
Moore comedian and blaxploitation actor
known for his dolomite movies the movie
covers Moore's life during the period
right before he became a star through to
when his first film opens in Los Angeles
and Eddie Murphy in a comeback of sorts
does a truly outstanding job as more
according to screenwriters Scott
Alexander and Larry karaszewski Murphy
was their only choice for the role and
they wrote the script with him in mind
the three had met way back in 2003 and
bonded over their love of the real-life
more and tell him I want him out of here
in 24 hours and 23 of them are already
gone
Murphy's co-stars turn in some fine
performances to Wesley Snipes is
wonderful playing the director of
dolomite d'Urville Martin and divine joy
Randolph is tremendous as lady read
Moore's longtime friend and confidant
and then there are the costumes designed
by Oscar winner Ruth Carter which are as
much the stars of dolomite as the actors
themselves swagger thy name is dolomite
written and directed by Macon Blair I
don't feel at home in this world anymore
is a comedy thriller starring melanie
lynskey and elijah wood the movie is
about a woman recently robbed of a
laptop who joins her oddball neighbor in
trying to track it down when the police
won't do anything about it they quickly
end up in way over their heads and
mayhem inevitably ensues Blair's double
duty as writer and director works well
here he's crafted a tight standalone
movie that feels like a throwback to the
sort of low-budget quirky independent
features that so rarely get attention
these days Lynne skis performances Ruth
is pretty terrific - bringing life to
the every woman who has finally had
enough and then there's wood who has in
the past few years excelled at playing
the weirdo and his role as Tony here is
no exception
Steven Soderbergh's 2011 film haywire
boasts a large and distinguished cast
including Gina Carano Michael Fassbender
Ewan McGregor and Channing Tatum the
film revolves around Mallory Kane an
ex-marine working for a hush-hush
company who carries out covert special
ops Kane thinks her next job is going to
be a piece of cake and of course it
turns out to be anything but haywire is
a clever action thriller that's full of
twists and turns
Soderberg not only directed the film but
acted as the director of photography and
editor - under two different pseudonyms
maybe as a result of that you won't find
much filler in this movie which flows
along at a good clip the film is
probably most notable for its hotel
fight scene between Carano and
Fassbender a nearly three-minute
sequence that's a sexy as it is
bone-crushing of course haywire is so
much more than that but it's still fun
to see Carano using her MMA background
to give her opponent a good kicking
David Mackenzie's 2016 neo western hell
or high water was a huge critical
success and garnered numerous
nominations from various outlets
including four Academy Award nominations
however while it received all kinds of
attention from film enthusiasts it's all
little success at the box office
the movie stars Chris Pine and Ben
Foster as brothers who turned to bank
robbery to pay off a loan and save the
family ranch while they're hunted by a
veteran Texas Ranger who is determined
to stop them seems foolish was that
today's robbing banks trying to live
spending money this movie might seem
like the typical cops-and-robbers story
but screenwriter Taylor Sheridan has
written a story that is much more than
that and while hell or high water looks
like a Western it's actually more of a
heist film a crime drama in a cowboy hat
it's awfully pretty to look at - thanks
to the work of cinematographer Giles
Newtons and the picture-perfect scenery
of New Mexico standing in for Northwest
Texas throw in a score written by Nick
Cave and Warren Ellis you got a recipe
for success when Tom Hardy isn't busy
starring in big-budget summer
blockbusters he tends to stick to
smaller more personal projects take
Locke for example this film is unique in
a few ways it unfolds in real time takes
place in one location and while you'll
hear some familiar voices the only
person ever seen on screen is Hardy the
movie follows Ivan Locke a construction
supervisor who learn
the colleague with whom he had an affair
has gone into premature labor determined
to be there for the birth Locke abandons
his job and his family to make the long
drive from Birmingham to London along
the way he makes and receives a number
of phone calls some of which will change
his life forever now you might think
just watching a guy driving a car and
talking on the phone for 80 minutes
would be boring even if that guy is Tom
Hardy in some cases this would be true
but that isn't a problem for Locke not
only is Hardy brilliant in this but the
movie manages to be both tense and
hypnotic despite its intimate scale the
movies supporting cast is impressive -
and includes Ruth Wilson Tom Holland
Olivia Colman and Andrew Scott not that
you'd know it Kodi smit-mcphee Michael
Fassbender and Ben Mendelsohn star in
the 2015 Western slow fest the first
feature film by director John McLean the
young Scotsman Jay Cavendish leaves
Scotland to search across America for
the woman he loves and along the way
hires bounty hunter Silas Selleck as a
guide
little does Cavendish know however
Selleck has his own motives for making
the journey across the Old West things
only get more complicated when SELEX old
gang leader gets involved unsurprisingly
it all goes south real quick slow West
is one of those movies that some might
call a slow burn the action isn't
particularly fast or furious instead it
gradually builds tension as it goes
finally ending with one heck of a bang
the film is gorgeous - without leaning
too heavily on the style of its
predecessors don't go into this
expecting sweeping vistas and epic
wide-angle shots here McLean's framing
is tight and intimate but it really does
work for this kind of movie when startup
was released in 2014 it was roundly
praised by critics the prison set drama
stars Jack O'Connell and Ben Mendelsohn
and both men were lauded for their
performances in the film unfortunately
while the critics loved startup the film
wasn't widely seen by audiences
especially those in the United States
the film follows violent juvenile
prisoner Eric Love who is transferred to
an adult prison due to his difficult
behavior as it happens he has moved to
the same prison where his father
Neville love is serving a life sentence
Neville works for the crime lord who
runs the prison and father and son
clashed throughout the film Eric doesn't
much care for being bossed around by his
dad while Neville just wants Eric to be
able to get out of prison
one day there's a lot to unpack in this
ultra gritty movie and it's definitely
not your typical prison film it's not a
film for the faint of heart either and
doesn't exactly pull its punches when it
comes to violence however Mendelsohn and
O'Connell really do shine as a family
under lockdown struggling to survive
based on Bernard Cornwell's the Saxon
stories the Netflix series the last
Kingdom is a historical drama about King
Alfred the Great the show blends actual
events from the ninth century with
fiction in order to tell the story of
Alfred's unification of the anglo-saxon
kingdoms at the outset of the series
this land has been conquered and
captured by the Vikings with only King
Alfred and his kingdom of Wessex
standing in their way in particular the
last Kingdom follows suit tread of
bebbanburg a noble Saxon who's kidnapped
as a slave and then raised by the Danes
who tread is subsequently forced to
choose between the people that raised
him in the land of his birth the last
Kingdom has everything you'd want in a
historical drama covering this time
period brutal fighting great characters
intriguing storylines and some gorgeous
cinematography and all those English
accents well they're just the bonus yeah
okay so this is a Marvel property which
isn't exactly the most hidden franchise
on the planet still despite the MCU
being quite prolific agents of shield
seems to have passed many audiences by
and with season 7 being the show's last
hurrah now would be a perfect time to
give it another look agents of shield
follows the exploits of a number of
agents within the clandestine
organization including Avengers hero
agent Phil Coulson
hey guys over the last six seasons the
team is tangled with a range of enemies
from the movies and beyond and the show
does recognize the continuity of the MCU
although some fans have wished for a
little more overlap with the films still
that shouldn't stop you from adding this
one to your Netflix queue the stories
and characters in the show are
surprisingly rich and it's totally worth
investing a little time to catch up with
them all based on the comic book of the
same name I am NOT okay with this is the
story of Sidney a seventeen-year-old
girl who is trying to deal with high
school the death of her dad and her
newly discovered superpowers when Sidney
experiences an emotional outburst one
day she realizes she's able to move
objects with her mind and eventually
attempts to control these powers with
mixed results in addition to her
newfound powers Sidney is also trying to
manage the feelings she has for both of
her friends Dena and Stan
Sophia Lillis is terrific in her role as
Sydney since her appearance in 2017 it
the young actress has proven herself in
a number of different projects and I am
NOT okay with this is yet another step
in her rise to stardom all in all this 7
episode Netflix original series is sure
to be relatable to anyone who
experienced the little awkwardness
during their teenage years or
telekinesis based on the 1967 novel
ritual by David Pinter 1973's the wicker
man follows police sergeant Neil Howie
who visits the remote community of
summer Isle in order to investigate a
report of a missing girl how he's a very
religious man and is absolutely dismayed
to find the islanders are practicing
something decidedly not Christian
leading the locals and hampering Howie
is Lord summer Isle played to perfection
by a terrifying Christopher Lee the
disturbingly friendly Townsville do
everything they can to obscure the truth
of course and Howie's investigation
quickly leads them down a very dark path
indeed there are some decidedly strange
things going on in the Wicker Man and
the serene beauty of the island is
juxtaposed against the utter depravity
of the Islanders the performances are
outstanding too particularly Edward
Woodward's you really feel his struggle
as he tries to make sense of what is
happening on the island all while trying
to do his job as a policeman and remain
strong in his faith and then there's
that ending which is probably one of the
most iconic scenes in horror movie
history if you've never seen the
version of the wicker man you're gonna
want to add this horror gem to your
watchlist check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]